I'll start from the last diagram it
shows the nav coming in from the right
see how it's over here off the canvas
and then it comes in and covers the
canvas on the right side this one is
wrong because this property translate
negative 300 pixels means that the
navbar is starting 300 pixels to the
left of the viewport so this can't be
right in this example it shows that
navbar showing up from well nowhere it's
not over here this is wrong according to
the CSS over here it clearly exists
somewhere in this example the navbar
starting off to the left of the viewport
but then when it comes in it pushes the
content off the viewport this is wrong
because the position of the nav element
is absolute which means that when it
comes in it'll actually just cover the
existing content all that is to say that
this diagram accurately shows the way
that navbar will show up on screen and
there you have it this is a good way to
visualize the way your navbar is sliding
in on the screen